au prochain numéro 1 de la draft n'en
déplaise à certains
on dit en grain et on va pouvoir en
débattre de ça maintenant il peut pas
atteindre son corps faire maintenir sa
qualité pas à ces puissances évident
sur les bécanes tous les cris des débuts
allons
agréer mes et énervé que
dirait que ce soit toujours le premier
truc que je lis et sam en fait je suis
pas du tout aisée puisque moi-même les
sur les poses de compte on va dire très
très mainstream immobilier je vais
toujours lire ça m'intéresse pas ce que
fait d'elle quand on parle de la draft
puis si intéressant chaque fois que je
vais surtout sur chet jeudi deux trucs
pas ça fera pas il faut 30 kilos en plus
et ouais c'est une petite victoire one
banias m'a franchement le résumé cetto
mrena ça si ça marche aussi si on pense
qu'il va être une pièce qu'on voit tous
nous à gonzague à ce qu'on a dit aux
fidèles et 19 voix vous allez être
choqués clairement parce que
voici parce que tu peux la laideur
pourquoi est presque toujours à ce que
parce que c'est un défenseur
générationnel honnêtement
t1 moins bon défenseur qui va doubler
pour moi eva noblesse est ce que j'ai le
mieux de mieux évaluer de tous les temps
et puis je suis et la draft donc
premiers bords 2018 avant c'était voilà
c'était toujours garder un petit peu d
alex avait l'impression scouter mais
c'était le processus était pas parler
même et puis 2018 2019 et 2020 n'était
pas selon moi en intérieur les les draps
fait plus fournie en termes de potentiel
défensif d'eva noblesse et le meilleur
que j'évalue et honnêtement les tendres
elle il est juste derrière et en fait si
c'est pas que il n'est pas bon c'est que
tu es mon but c est ce ça veut dire
comment je crois au potentiel défensif
des bonnes nouvelles c'est un vrai mais
c'est gelé en numéro on entend les
pendants plaindra retrouvez moi parce
que pour moi en je vais un mec qui à ce
que je pense être un ce qu'ils
générationnel et dans cette draft j'ai
qu'un seul mec que je dois être généreux
scène dans un truc et alors c'est un
truc que tout le monde on va des foires
peut-être pas mettre en avant mettre en
valeur en tout temps au delà mais cette
année j'ai décidé de le mettre en avant
parce que pour moi la protection de
cercle et l'impact défensif de septembre
n ya aucun joueur qui fait une chose
mieux que ça selon moi on pourrait me
dire le chou de jabari 6 peut-être
peut-être mais je suis je pense m'en le
band chéreau est un incroyable attaquant
je pense menace potentielle là mais je
pense que ça sera jamais l'option numéro
1 d'une équipe prétendante au titre du
coup je me dis 20 dans cette rafle a je
voulais aller surtout voilà je vais
aller sur
genre que je pense qu'ils je pense à un
truc spécial dans sa tâche un truc
spécial
spécial de plus spécial que les autres
c'est la protection de serques la
capacité à défendre de piété - une
quantité sur le terrain l'attaqué
adverse elle est chamboulé attaques
adverses et elle peut pas vraiment
toujours mettre en avant ce que m'étant
pas ce qu'elle veut elle pas attaquer
cirque comme le fait beaucoup de driving
qui donc du coup elle se retrouverait
totalement dépendante de l'adresse
extérieure on parle de fois c'est un peu
problématique c'est un joueur qui plaît
ne l'a pas mal de lacunes physiques en
attaque on en regarde on va mettre dans
le clip mais mais voilà c'est un joueur
qui sur le premier rideau deuxième
rideau contestation main droite main
gauche capacité à lire les trucs
capacités surtout à n'avoir rien à foot
est allé au contact chaque fois donc
même des fois être sûre des posters et
vraiment je trouve
très impressionnant extrêmement
impressionnant alors c'est tout autre
chose surtout ce que tu as dis moi c'est
vrai que je te sais c'est le numéro n'a
raté que c'était response quittera
numéro en tout cas moi je suis moi je
suis pas sûr qu'il sera un numéro
honnêtement je suis pas sûr je ne sais
pas franchement je sais pas j'ai ouvert
on a dit storytelling c'est en tous les
sens et on échoue crise mais ça se calme
et on sera champions il y aura tjrs être
qu'il y aura d'autres matches un peu
plus smart money cetera mais
pourquoi je ne vais pas numéro qu'on
avait fait notre planète drafté à demi
nu méro deux dans le même tir parce que
je valide toujours salut alexis
installe-toi parmi nos eaux par le chat
comme d'ailleurs où je passe les petites
commandes nouvelles est toujours un
joueur qui peut créer bâle ots - qui
peuvent ou pas aller dans une équipe
tout pourri parce que j'avais evans
moblie un peu plus bas l'an dernier
alors si vous me suivait depuis un petit
peu de temps vous avez entendu parler
sur twitter et cetera vous savez que
j'ai lâché beaucoup beaucoup de titres
chocs émane mobile pas que je croyais
pas dans le genre j'ai toujours dit que
c'était un potentiel de all star que
c'est un phénomène de ouf mexes n'est
pas l'alpha d'une équipe à la manière
que vous dites de rudy gobert n'est pas
l'alpha du jazz monde c'est dans cette
même logique
et donc du coup je
descendais un peu evans m'oblige il
avait quand même dans mon top 4 j'avais
luthérien de personnellement derrière
notre amie kate est ce qu'au liban thiel
tongren il ya un truc est très
sous-évalué je trouve chez ce joueur
parce qu'il ya côté collectif parce
qu'il a su physique parce que cette
image là c'est la puissance du joueur
c'est un joueur qui est extrêmement
puissant et qui est physiquement bien
plus évoluée que ce qu'on annonce que ce
qu'on pense
de façon générale je dis des choses des
fois j'ai l'impression que l'image du
croque un gringalet du minnesota paf à
l'aise dans son corps alors que lille va
à la bataille va là bas car il se tape
toujours le mec le plus physique parce
que drew timmy peut pas le faire en fait
et comme tu le dis il va aux bleus qui
tirent contact qui défend les extérieurs
etc aya du clip où il est en un contre
un sur paolo gontero et pouvant qu'il
roulait fonce dessus on va voir comment
ça va se passer je vous dis pas mais
parle au bond quiros et c'est un très
beau bébé il s'adjugera de lacq dans le
pot dit il ya un peu de ça un peu on
nous pose la question le profite à l'or
dites le profil devant du rêve protéger
la 3.1 est ce que c'est vraiment
possible ça
on va regarder les stats on va jouer
petite emma
je vais je vais vous mettre sa main et
chaque petite envergure nous vous l'avez
actualisé 2015 de 130 cm d'envergure de
coin système métrique voiture du 7 pieds
2 et 229 des jours du 7 7 5 dans les
rues durant un très très long 88 kg je
pense que c'est pas actualisés aurait
demandé à julien qui pensent que ça
fasse travailler aux côtés de zinc dont
80 du tueur avait fait qu'ils ont échoué
le bras dit mais je pense qu'on est plus
actuellement sur 20 92 95 kg frais
accordées sur le site de monza gars il
est en 2022 au consensus on peut
regarder le big board tout ici en fait
il est voilà temps partagé là on est la
moitié ne mettra la moitié de métro 2
avec bonne car au bout pour l'instant
personne n'a jamis me sens donc c'est ça
tu vois ya un an il est actualisé elle
est actualisée juste admettre bonne
pierrot en es tu crois que c'est ben qui
a repassé vonn qui a repassé un regret
nord la banda très moulant c'est pas
grave ça sera incessamment sous peu
aucun souci
dans les stats alors ils jouent 25
minutes sur 40 minutes globalement il
est titulaire ça c'est évident les huit
paniers tenté par match 64% de réussite
on voit que à trois points on est sur
trois tentatives parce qu'il ya un
volume intéressant c'est pas voulu
m'aider à 47% à proposer que des mois
47% à 3 sur un volume quand même qui s
est développée et regardera journée du
clip distance nba mécanique rapide aux
lancers-francs petit volume de lancers
francs mais on va comparer ensuite
d'avancé sur le nombre de ter tonte est
prévu près du panier compagne
74 pensent aux lancers francs ce qui est
intéressant puisqu'il est correct sans
être élite on parle de très bon niveau
aujourd'hui viendra 80% de réussite mais
sur cette 96ème intéressante on est sur
8 points 9 rebonds alors qu'ils jouaient
dans notre intérieur de routine
même si c'est un intérieur qui est pas
un excellent rebondeur mais c'est quand
même de bix deux passes décisives stade
que moi je trouve qu'ils ne veuillent
pas son talent la passe on en reparlera
et un maire conscient que ça va
0,5 style 3,3 blog sur tout ce qui est
impressionnant très très impressionnant
deux portions de blocs voilà
après avoir écrit l'article sur voit le
faire car je me dis ouais c'est pas où
mais en fait ça
le pivot géorgien dover note o'byrne le
baobab
19% 2 contre lui à 19 pour fin de compte
cela tient sur cinq quand il est sur le
terrain les contrer ces contrées voilà
je crois
dans douze ou treize je crois 12 13 ils
sont pas beaucoup est à plus de 15 cette
année j'ai regardé mais ouais c'est
n'importe quoi je viens donc mais cette
ordure vous avez ici allez le sulfure
twitter vous s'arrêta pead martial perdu
c'est une mine d'or pour l'un
de plus ici de 10,85 il doit gonzaga
donc il va en profiter on va rencontrer
je pense au combat il n'y est pas mais
risque de faire mesurer on mesure tout
reprendre à la base cela magistrats ou
la taille des morts dont quatre à son
bureau puis on verra si c'est un bon
signe astrologique chinois bateau si ça
vous savez tout ça au combat le nombre
de fautes donc des gens qui arrivent à
rester sur le terrain 14,5 points ça
c'est pour les stocks les stats en brut
juste avant d'assurer cette annonce et
je vous donne les ressources est ce que
tu peux nous donner le contexte gonzaga
rapidement
ouais on perd et se monte à kde donc
équipe à passer une nouvelle une équipe
qui a perdu quatre titulaires par
rapport à l'année dernière dont
challenge corée qui se perdent je vais
là il ya
un an 3 rake reconnaît marc de cet art
est sur la fin d'année en réalité donc
andrew neymar des broutilles sont les
deux joueurs qui sont revenus il y avons
donc jo dan ce trotteur qui est un
portoricain qui étaient remplaçants
pichot quasiment jamais l'an passé
qu'ils postent 3,20 dans cette année ils
ont récupéré rassir bolton qui voit
state avant un transfert qu'ils ont une
stricte au début de sa carrière car un
futur joueur d'europe latran et qui est
très très très bon et qu'il est une
équipe que ce qui me retenait l'époque
qui était exactement si bolt de télé qui
payent aux sept victimes faisaient
exactement une équipe qui appliquait pas
si profondes que ça c'est qu'après quand
ça sort du banc tannique manhunter sa
liste donc aider des très bons freshman
qui seront là l'an prochain
je t'aime rennes c'est la pierre
angulaire du système défensif et mais
c'est pas la pierre angulaire le système
offensif c'est plutôt de route imid
finisseur proche du panier où il marque
un très bon créateur surpiqué d'envol
les marques bolton s'était future mme
joueurs d'euroligue d'eurocup donc des
genres sûr je pense
être aussi de mettre bien voilà qui met
très bien en valeur votre outil millet
une piétonne grain et ce trotteur
qu'elle sut ndi c'est très moderne ça je
vis de sa cour et poursuivre
très en détail la wcc je dirais pas
pourquoi peut-être y aura des infos
prochainement
[Musique]
il ya une sur domination de mega sur
domination devant haga ils sont dans
leur level et à les autres
chaque mois je suis à aller peut-être
peut-être be why you peut les embêter
parfois cette année peut-être sainte
mais ruiz san francisco mais c'est plus
grandes stars raison
leur dîner dernier cette année surtout
qu'ils ont perdu col caisse et cody ross
sont à tout le monde donc ouais c'est
une sur domination pour ça que dans les
clips qu'on a choisi c'était que ça
stagne et duke notamment
il s'ag duke
donc ils perdent quand du coin c'était
vraiment un super match
on aurait pu prendre note qu'en tués ou
s'il est le match contexte face c'est
une équipe qui met beaucoup de gros
match dans son début de saison pour un
petit peu perdues gonfler son son staff
sky et donc sans difficulté 2 dt
landrier et puis donc c'est cool aux
attentes arrête de voir rondes et des
papes équipe avant la march madness que
l'an dernier alors
qu'ils avaient déjoué un complot trop de
bello qui était le numéro deux il était
numéro 1 et cause des conditions si ça
s'était pas fait donc on a vu avec des
petites et si c'était effectivement on
le voit au début la défonce epiq systems
qui fait penser à turin en 2009 des
wings et pas du tout
ouais
sur leur début de saison en conférence
il ya du très lourd il ya des traits
sombres c'est sans commentaire et donc
ils ont affronté des plus grosses
équipes donc tu l'as dit texas texas
tech
du louvre on a pu voir un côté comme ça
alabama à l'album alabama avec l'équipe
avait personne à l'intérieur chaque jour
de 13 extrait la nba mais qu'ils ont
perdu contre alabama ils ont perdu
contre alain desbois qui a tapé dans la
même saison duke et que n'importe quoi
tout kozak a et b lors donc voilà la
bête noire des des gros noms
pour garder dans les stats avancé alors
j'essaie de regarder un petit point dans
les commentaires beaucoup de mouvements
gonzague a lancé une équipe connue pour
se construire sur des joueurs qui font 6
min 20 sec arlon ben voilà ça je sais
comment ça peut changer alors désigné
attire les attire les oies naines
d'attirer les one donne et ils ont
raison mais ça deviendra jamais je pense
les fabriques auendon à la moto n'était
ni du combat revanche pas au cra
différence moyenne les succès en fait
finalement c'est plus s'exclame m quel
match est que gonzague alors oui comme
sa gamme est sec ce qui était très
proche de thiennes qu'ils ont joué
ensemble et jouent ensemble - qu'ils
soient du minnesota tous les deux nos
maladies une connexion mais si je
regarde de l'économie de l'an prochain
par exemple je suis pas sûr qu'on était
des top 10 non revenant d'un très
honnêtement non donc à prévoir même des
pépites faudra voir si tu n'entres aux
varois la draft ou voilà mais c'est plus
cher est effectivement des programmes
l'on pense
enfin qu'ils sont bien fades et one
donne ils ont des pattes de wasselonne
surprenant sabonis est collins et des
moines savoie lycéens sophomore il voit
sa deuxième année à collins c'est un one
donne mais souvent voie la plus connue
pour ses pour sortir les corps et qui se
perd pour sortir avec china nuclear de
la chimie aura les jeux jouent à l'oeil
pour moi qui à sa place à didier je
pense et ça c'est tout se passe bien et
ce type de genre l'avant mais en fait
cher et seuls des one donne un peu
différents styles mais qu'ils étaient
prêts à sacrifier d'impact offensif pour
dans des super collectif est mis en
avant tant que ce soit role players plus
plus sourd à la pierre angulaire
défensive ou des choses comme ça
d'ailleurs on peut le voir rapidement
chattam la demande qui est la méga star
est attendu à l'image d'un début de
saison dernier n'est que le quatrième
volume de tir de l'équivalent on est
assez proches un banc par rapport à
entre neymar mais on est short quatrième
volume de tir ou alors vous avez le site
la mode je vous ai mis le la ressource
comme ça je vous la remet ici dans les
commentaires que vous avez les deux
sites ressources que j'utilise beaucoup
matteo pexinois
j'utilise très peu bordeaux ville parce
que je passe intelligente pour ça
l'adhérent bartoli après ça c'est très
très cool mais pour le stream chinois
c'est bon c'est donc avec cela mais
utilisé par toufik aussi c'est pas de
communistes vous inquiétez pas
très intéressante
nous donne quoi comment il faut que ça
nous donne la répartition des tirs vous
avez ici les tirs près du panier vous
avez la répartition des deux poings long
la répartition des trois points et à
chaque fois vous avez l'efficacité
contingent du jeu et vous avez le
pourcentage de fois où le tir et pris
après une passe décisive à
[Musique]
84% au fier d'avoir j'allais venir là
dessus comme c'est la moitié de ces tirs
ont fait d'honorer partie répartition
qui est déjà une bière on a 50 % près du
panier 40% près du trois points et un
petit pour dean between mais voilà
majoritairement 50% près du panier 85%
saartjie élite
ce qui est donc quand vous me parler
d'un joueur pack puissant là vous avez
une information comme quoi c'est un
joueur extrêmement puissants les bêtes
physique comme challenge wayne ne sont
pas à ce niveau là on l'a vu ensemble la
dernière fois les oscars che bout et
l'état vides mccormack les grosses bcd
grosse bestiaux ne sont pas ce niveau là
john williams l'attrait de new york a
joué zerg il dit même si c'est pas une
brute mais les cours volume quoi les
groupes à part comme tirées pendant m
nico
rien et en plus on peut le couple est à
autre chose donc déjà bon beaucoup de
tirs qui sont pris par lui même c'est à
dire qu'il se crée son propre accès au
niveau du panier et quand il va au
cercle on voit que quasiment une fois
sur deux trouve un lancer franc alors je
vous dis quasiment une fois sur deux
parce que je mets en relation le
pourcentage de fumeurs wade par rapport
au pourcentage de tirs près plat du
panier donc on est quasiment sûr cours
de grains sur à savoir qui provoque des
fautes qui va provoquer des lancers qui
va qui a créé des pagnes à au
pourcentage est donc on ne sait pas plus
il ya un combo de taille touchait qu'à
sa puissance les deux les deux parce que
va t-il dit très souvent défendu
par des joueurs quand même assez
développée quand on pense à
juke il avait un bonne qui inquiétait
physique pizol si c'est pas les nombres
défenseur composa texas il a été défendu
par
part très mitchell qui avait un gros
volume qu'un gros profils donc il a
reconnu des défenses intéressante et
ensuite il que certaines pers % près du
lancer franc par le trois points on a vu
que c'était 40% de 7 sur donc un volume
intéressant car on dit 5,6 pour cent à 3
points
le tyran 400 shoot c'est quand même un
joueur qui arrive parfois sur un petit
dribble à se créer un petit décalage
alors fin 2006 alors qu'il fait de
maîtresses parce que il ya de la
fluidité donc quand on parle de liberté
ça c'est des choses que tu aimes bien
dira t'on pas normal pour la taille d'un
certain temps
avant d'aller choix du clip est trop
filer la parole est encore un peu dans
le dans le tchat on peut regarder chez
vous peut explorer pour avoir à peu près
le même sauf aux malades du code couleur
ça c'est mon côté comme jeter chaque
fois prof de maternelle j'aime bien les
couleurs
on a
du verre partout c'est pas normal ça
veut dire que normalement il ya du coup
je vous voyais jouer une répartition
classique et du rouge et du blanc dans
cet effet verre partout so cholet
turnover et on va regarder sur du clip
pourquoi l'expliquer c'est un joueur qui
est dominant par rapport au niveau n 6
et par rapport à tous les joints
dossiers chauds tirs à trois points il
est dans le top 10 aux tirs à trois
points dans le top 2 20% il donne 20%
sur le tir à deux points notamment sur
le tir près du panier où il est le top
du top
vous avez des idées dans le top 20 % sur
le pourcentage de de tir contré donc le
bloc par sa tête comme tu l'as dit et
puis globalement voilà c'est un joueur
quand il est sur le terrain impact ultra
positif en attaque et défensivement pour
toi est ce que le profit statistiques un
peu plus hommage que l'impression
visuelle de base
les premières statistiques avancées en
plus dommage que le prouve le pote le
profil statistique brut pour un joueur
qui à 14 points et 8 rebonds pour
d'accord des références de seconde zone
donc arrachée mais en fait quand tu l'as
dit mais il est évident dans énormément
de domaines il est évident dans pas mal
de domaines saints row moi j'ai ce qu'on
voit sur la capacité voilà est à influer
sur le jeu et influer sur le collectif
de tracer un teamplay requis plus plus
quitté gagner qui fait gagner son équipe
par sa présence par le fait que
défensivement ils influent
incroyablement j
ouer donc tout ça les met en avant oui
comment kate est à la base du système
gonzague reste années on parle de
système gonzague à cette année
défensivement c'est qu'est le système
voilà
en attaque et défensivement lors c'est
vrai que tu l'as dit le point d'ancrage
en bas c'est notre ami notre édito
outils me mais celui qui rend possible
tout cet étalage qui la rendent possible
cette efficacité cette stupidité c'est
notre ami de cet homme quand on à romain
le romain d'envergure notre ami le grand
le cos l'inimitable estimant à
strasbourg qui vient de follow la chaîne
et ça messieurs dames c'est le symbole
de la réussite les impalas on a gagné on
a cassé le jeu
9 de romain avec nous installe
tranquillement on espère que tu as passé
ta passer une bonne journée une bonne
semaine au global mais tu n'es pas tu
serais tu es un grand homme c'est ça et
dur le ciel qui s'est abonné avec son
prêt merci beaucoup c'est hyper gentil
tapas merci merci merci c'est très cool
de ta part 2
de se tenir là la chaîne l'asean
envergure et notre travail au quotidien
on va pouvoir passer jour du clip
officiel des choses a été rencontré les
stats mais sinon le film pas le rap non
je t'en prie donc tu nous as pris du
pour redonner un peu de contexte tu nous
as pris des du clip contre quelle équipe
et pour nous montrer quoi
exec
duke il fallait mettre duke c'était un
peu le gros gros mc est des moments où l
on le voit des fins de rendre les eaux
sur cauet c'est de contenir du drive ii
par le band hero il est un peu face à
mark williams aussi et un match contre
santa clara donc en ewc c'est parce que
c'est un match joué et on voit la sueur
domination sur domination là le premier
clip la passe excusez moi c'est que tu
vas faire un peu un peu un peu de
tournée on voit un peu touche on le voit
un coup d'oeil on le voit tirer on le
voit passer on voit tout son influence
défensive on voit surtout un truc que je
vous met en avant on le voit résister à
des joueurs puissants
poste bas il sait et on voit qui tient
vraiment bien les contacts donc voir
contredit ou qu'on sait moins contre
deux genres d'autre part largo silva qui
est le pivot 302 texane récompense à
kévin aubeneau sur le terrain je passe
ma défaveur les quatre jours très
puissant aussi et du côté de john keogh
mark williams qui sont des profils
athlétique nbi
complètement complètement on le voit on
voit passer aussi de trois fois des
bonnes bâtiment voisin peu ses limites
aussi un moment on va l'avoir rarement
ou des verticalités sur le drive ce
qu'il va se faire pas mal contre qui
peut se faire contrer on va avoir un
moment là une capacité à finir au cercle
sur la transition quand tu dois vraiment
il y allait y aller c'est un peu
compliqué mais on voit surtout voilà
l'influencent défensif je trouve qu'ils
aient vraiment notable dans ces matches
là et voilà des possessions sur band
hero ou bas je crois qu'il y ait les
stats et à trois fois quatre fois pour
point de mire au drive en un contre un
sur sept il marque qui se font
assez assez très notable pour un joueur
qui draguait un peu sur tout le monde
cette année
devait donner
une alors on l'a dit défensivement il
change la géométrie alors là il ya une
défense incroyable j'ai léger le même
clip on l'apprêté clippage exactement le
même parce que tellement cette défense
latérale sur paolo gontero et les
superbes
enfin tous les clips menu big excusez
moi si on devait noter sur des finances
et enfin intégrer ce n'était pas
n'importe quel qui est bon c'était le
début de saison il jouait pas beaucoup
mais il annule complètement to drive
c'est un profil athlétique en fait cette
capacité à tenir latéralement un joueur
depuis la ligne d'eau extérieure de
vraiment l'amener au niveau du panier et
vignères le contre et derrière on
encaisse dans le contact sans reculer
c'est un truc de fou
j'ai pas énormément de situations où il
est face à une attaque important de bâle
qui change de direction j'en ai très peu
finalement mais il arrive à annuler la
prise de position des prises de position
au niveau de l'accès au très haut niveau
du slash face à de très très haut depuis
quelque temps il casse vraiment le drive
adverse et on l'a dit côté côté faible
on va le voir des blocs côté faible une
bonne rotation capacité de venir prendre
et des airs prendre
il ya le ya souvent des fois aussi où tu
as l'impression qu'il est passé mais
qu'il ait pas battu parce que je veux
dire ouais il arrive à saint claude il
s'est fait passer ligne de fond et
finalement il revient il n'est pas battu
il arrive à tenir si on à défaut
principal moi que je note chez le joueur
c'est dans le drive en fait c'est pas
c'est pas compliqué c'est voilà c'était
cette capacité à ce que vous êtes très
bien et vannes mobile par exemple l'an
dernier pour les comparaisons c'est de
partir depuis postaux quand il reprend
un premier contact qu'ils arrêtent
souvent son dribble y arrive pas changer
de direction pas très à l'aise dans ce
dans ce domaine du jeu
complètement
naïf qu'il faisait toujours montré en
effet c'est un poids des absents il fait
des trucs pas très bien non ce ne serait
pas drôle de commencer donc on a bien
envie c'était un jeu offensivement sur
le post up a du mal encore il en joue
très peu de façon je pense qu'on va pas
lui en demander énormément on a bien
plus exposé il est meilleur voilà donc
dans le pick and pop dans la capacité il
ya une question de tout daninos le petit
wang ouais ça il est il est capable de
le faire franchement il est capable de
faire un petit turner un jumper il est
tellement grand il a aussi un très bon
touché il a 64 corse pour sa danse et
franc admettre c'est à son âge
franchement c'est la mécanique est belle
et bonne ya paillard un parasite donc
ouais ça il en est capable mais souci
c'est plus le manque de verticalité
d'explosivité et le bougeant poster ça
c'est des deux trois trucs que je
voulais mettre en avant sur choses
encore améliorée défensivement mais moi
c'est surtout défensivement je suis là
dans leur halle a donc décidé moi je
trouve ce qu'il encaisse alors bas on va
passer de 200 fin de saison un peu de
cette comparaison filet avec evans
mobile mais je trouve qu'il encaisse de
le contacter sur le premier impact tu
vois mon nom mon fils en bas du corps a
l'air très costaud ouais mais c'est
vraiment impressionnant ça c'est pas du
colonel souvent tu rentres dedans c'est
toi qui recule donc moi ça je le veux
lui énormément ça il peut arriver en
première année en nba et il peut avoir
déjà en vraiment le défensif échanger
une défense me dit roman il a noté ce
qui est déjà fort et plus tu parles dans
le drive roman être que le fait de
pouvoir stopper s'élever ou prendre la
bonne décision même si c'est assez
rageant qu'un fort qi basket et qui fait
rarement des choses qui c'est on va
faire la course et dragon smaug
françois qui nous sommes en bien castro
de le contacter il suit bien toujours
les mains le vch un jour qui reste
verticale qui provoque pas de faute
à toi t on à vue de trois fois on a vu
deux ou trois fois la capacité juste à
se mettre juste par le fait d'être de
lever les bras de bouger un petit peu
les gens une ciel ils ne peuvent pas lui
tirer au-dessus quoi on le voit aussi
sur amirouche par l'hadopi de ressortir
du rémi roux ça c'est pas possible on va
le voir aussi sur josy bourran kitsch un
joueur de cinquième année un des
meilleurs joueurs de wcc à l'intérieur à
une très bonne carrière en héros je
pense mais il peut rien faire là il
entend il a 24 ans le mec en face on
sait où c'est un peu la leur relation a
elle aussi sur les passes il ya deux
trois très bonnes passes les capacités à
faire des mêmes des kick out part
demandé à voir les coupes de ses joueurs
à l'opposé il assez ont leurs élèves ce
dribble dans le dos pour le pas trois
points il en a fait un concentré gaulle
hier il en fait un petit peu lent ce
moment c'est vrai que c'est assez simple
c'est vraiment super impressionnant par
sa taille on va passer sur du clip
individuellement la patrie je trouve
qu'il a effectivement qu on avait dit
qu'il avait posée tant que seconde qui
fait des lapalissades à la passe qui
reflète son niveau de passe quand vous
parlez de dénis faire au niveau de pain
sec avec cave de passer directement on
passe direct est capable de passer au
sol la basse et de la maîtrise jours
s'il ya des joueurs qui vont côté ligne
de fond et que lui les situations post
au face au cercle il peut les trouver
sur un cut avec une mode poste capable
de passer par dessus il est très très
grand métis bien ça pour de la passe en
avant de passer à une main donc c'est
vraiment un passeur
plus que fonctionnel c'est la mecque qui
va te fluidifier 900 et qui dans un pick
and roll ou dans une milieu de zones qui
ont joué des équipes nba qui jouent aux
zones faudra toujours le coup des cages
c'est un mec j'ai donné ce que j'ai noté
sur le dans le champ mais ce coût tirent
les portes il reconnaît rapidement le
mismatch que ce soit pour lui ou pour
les coéquipiers donc voilà vraiment un
cul parce qu'un très développée chez
chez ce jeune là des deux côtés du temps
on passe pour le clip donc là on est
face à texas tech qui est une équipe
intéressante de big town un peu
surprenante ya beaucoup de transferts vu
qu'ils ont récupérés chris byrd d'un
pardon excusez moi je te dis les gones
noir n'est pas perdue birds mais ils ont
son assistant qui a pris le relais ils
ont fait venir md mais comme d'avion de
warren qui par un extérieur assez
intéressant vétéran kevin aubin nord qui
aimeraient avoir une très belle carrière
en europe posant des grands quitté du
côté de râles roberts notre ami de van
gogh français venait le punching bag la
route n'a donné la rose qui montrent
clairement température qui très très
agressifs et donc là on commence
directement par une bonne passe sur
inquiète quand je vous disais voilà
lecture sur du zealot passer par dessus
ça c'est ce que veut nous faire notre
ami cet hommage à quoi j'ai ce que j'ai
envie des relations ce qu'on va dire
dans les 15 prochaines minutes il est né
en 2002 et il fait de médecins voilà
ayez de ça en tête parce que c'est pas
normal
l'aja mais aussi je sais je suis souvent
assez nul sur les systèmes des fois on
n'a pas ça se paye pick-and-roll c'est à
dire le fait de pouls d'un pick and roll
qui a appelé pape et avec un fer 3 ans
pas pour le poseur d'écran et pour un
troisième joueur qui va venir un petit
peu profité de l'espace pour sortir à
trois points et ça il le fait bien avant
et il tire
et de tirs très bien en fait ils tirent
très bien il va sur va sur livre sur la
ville il y en fait il il y as un train
très bon système dans un gars mais il
est capable aussi de sortir un peu de
justesse en france il faut il faut créer
un petit peu
c'est une question même temps comment
est ce qu'on fait pour retenir des clips
alors oui voilà revenus
la plainte si spécialisés etc
nous l'objectif à terme un jour c'est
d'avoir ce énergie qui est le
la référence plus plus plus moi pour
l'instant premier degré se passe
beaucoup par la russie vous voyez le
niveau de niveau 2 schlague on en est
c'est pour ça que vous avez parfois du
pixel et on essaie d'améliorer la mesure
où les lois je veux voir des matchs
youtube on diffuse pas mal on
cherchait vous avancez vous regardez au
niveau des longueurs de des vidéos et
vous trouvez tous les choses très
intéressantes assez rapidement pour moi
qui dis j'y suis pour le trail fondement
des dégâts mais tu sais on veut pas
déroger nous reste on autorise mais un
côté authentique tu vois sont un peu
pourri des images un peu pixels c'est ce
qu'on essaie de donner aux gens les
proches du peuple
est ce qui fait la jetta temps pour la
tête aussi il regarde regarde toujours
l'art large trois thèmes comme je trouve
comment ils résistent au contact c'est
ça change de look du tort à sur le haut
du corps pseudo c'est tout et c'est une
crainte twitter n est pas le physique de
l'intérieur en termes de musculature
qu'on peut qu'on pense d'eux mineur nba
mais là je suis désolé c'est comme un
exemple au contact passe un joueur
puissant
et me résiste c'est le haut c'est dur
texas tech qui recule 1 il prouve qu'il
est ici porté d'associer force est
prenant et force est prendre aucun peut
contester
we dance à saint-georges dit vraiment
ils arrêtent le contact même quand il va
nous mettre dans la course il a de la
patience à l'envoi sur ce clip n'a par
exemple pas revenir dessus et on a dream
de tyson warren donc qui est un joueur
expérimenté on voit qu'ils attendent
attentes alors je vais leur mettre à peu
près après ça on peut la voir chanter
l'hymne warren ici voilà drive ici on
vient d'en être tout de suite dans le
second rideau je m'arrête je sois pas
dans la feinte j'attends je suis patient
et comme je suis très long je viens
bloqué derrière donc il ya une bonne
gestion du compte des gains de budgets
sur le tmx est incertain
qui au fond défenseur hyper intéressant
capable de contrer dès demain sans
droite chimiques capables de contrer
avec un autre avec la main gauche
pendant que je lis dans l'artisanat mais
dans le fond c'est l'élite merci
beaucoup pour ce commentaire tant qu'ils
qui c'est ce qu'on peut lire de mieux
pour pour nous régaler
tu vois là sur la damnation contexte
vraiment le profil de la tour de
contrôle en convoi la les yeux la
capacité à animer tous types de drive
c'est c'est super super super
intéressant est la position contre
incombant de cheyrou elle est aussi
super g super forte l'année intéressante
parce que y'a juste avant la
pause de renversement ont le jeu te koop
excuse-moi romain censuré je suis désolé
roman il ya de le botter trop agressif
de normalement je l'avais demi je vous
le post est un pur jun azumi le fait
qu'on puisse poster des liens mais avec
les le boîtier connais pas deux fois que
j'arrive à des valides et fois je te
passe modérateur je te le ferai la
prochaine fois sinon tu m'envoies le
lien et je suis seule au public
aujourd'hui temps
ok ils sont pris tant sur le fond que
sur la première possession des cubes
qu'on a contre eux contre duke
qu'est ce qu'on voulait voir ses têtes
d'affiché témoigne contenu de
contrebande chéreau est ce qu'ils vont
se défendre en esquivant première action
du match abondent sur u10 est de driver
sur 7 et est en terre je trouve de
capacité 1 à à à parce que son corps
ultime bien utiliser son corps les mains
à absorber un contact venir à qu'on
appelle pas dissuadé il fait tout ce
qu'il fait est très propre alors je vais
essayer de la mettre un peu vraiment
ralenti on va essayer de regarder un peu
l'image pure donc on part de rêve -
gauche ou l'orientation est d'arrêter ce
qui est très très franche sur le joueur
ici on est à le corps en retrait de
baptiser la halle aux grains des bras
principalement voilà
on prend le premier à ragueneau le tien
et encore route un tout avec la longueur
des bras pour finalement venir contrer
au fond une très belle utilisation aussi
delà de la main qui conteste pas le tir
pour pouvoir mettre un petit peu
d'impact sur le corps du défenseur de le
garder une distance oui une intelligence
dans le mouvement pour justement gérer
ce contact là et le tenir correctement
la fin ma non pas sur son attaque elle
en a fait son plus gros problème en fait
c'est le drive c'est le rêve très
uniforme c'est un changement de
direction t'inquiète pas capable de
pouvoir accélérer extrêmement verticale
non plus très vertical non plus mais
trop beaucoup d'un autre près du panier
mais sur les nerfs de lancer c'est pas
là dessus qu'on va nous attendre et ce
n'est pas la suite il a conclu le
puissant fluidité c'est ça c'est pas
grave aucune aucun constat n est parfait
là on voit un petit peu les et les
problèmes un peu alors en plus six
banques qui en auraient marre ku'damm
ses deux futurs j'aurai une bière donc
ça aussi que c'est intéressant de voir
ça mais on va plus attendre sur
duppighem pape ou et là on va le voir là
je pense que j'aime bien parce que si en
fait il a compris que ce n'était pas
possible d'aller sur marc diab est à
vendre au fur et à mesure et qu'il
t-bonds va en europe tournant d'admis
distance est ce que c'est un ajustement
de marquion du staff qui lui dit ça va
être compliqué driver on sait que tu as
dû toucher et c'est plutôt de faire ça
ou en tout cas ils montrent qu'il est
capable quand même d'attaquer alors
makuza pays en ait de bonnes à deux dj
griffin mark williams qui font retrait
ville est très puissant encore une fois
pour tout ce qui est sûr les questions
athlétique du joueur essayez de
s'arrêter comme ça il enchaînait sur
radio terme de gainage sais c'est très
très fort c'est vraiment pas un beauf
qui est facile alors on voit qu'il y
bien la prise d'eau des tigres est fine
le ballon il est en retrait on protège
la perte de balle et ensuite on enchaîne
sur le one day one leg qu'on a vu déjà
moi j'ai 3 4 3 4 qui paye du mois de
l'aig donc c'est quelque chose qui me
veut il peut faire qu'il a travaillé
donc ici une réponse à leurs demandes
couverture punk héros très fort qu'ils
on voit que ça je ris doté
d'un prix c'est un jour qui donne pas
dans la fente quand je disais que il
restait verticale encore une fois on est
sur une feinte de tir il mord pas dedans
il ya la longueur la longueur dur pour
pouvoir contester le tir si jamais une
prise de tir et les petits buissons
remplacé très très vite en garde les les
petits appuis sur la réception du peuple
ne jette pas dans la feinte les pieds
sur place et est tout de suite je peux
tourner ma hanche est contesté le drive
ma droite pour aller contrer encore une
fois notre ami pour l'open quéro qui
manquent de variations dans son trip tu
vas peut-être dû changer de direction
manière dont il résista à l'impact aussi
ses impressionnantes genre de voulait
l'en on est sûr centrale la cerisaie
griffin on est vraiment sûr de la nuit
il annihile le truc quoi du coup
d'marron traduit le manque
de
traitements il est demain là mais
profite donc de sa standing reach c'est
l'affairé des grands nous excuser comme
comme disait aussi dans les commentaires
il prend alors qu'il prend pas
énormément de fautes arqiva ils
dissuadent énormément à son âge c'est ça
prouve qu'il a il saute pas pour rien
c'est quand sauter et donc ça c'est
aussi extrêmement rares sont à juste
encore un turnaround l'aï signée mort
contre mark williams je l'aï brimer les
mini mini même plus propre bah disons
que celui là il le travail de deux
agglos de ses plus en adaptation loterie
voilà des crises d'angoissé change
tellement il change alors une question
qui est la turquie et l'agent de
holmgren s'étalonne actuellement pour
cet
objectif maintenant il ya la pâte
d'argent pour le moment c'est interdit
sauf si des bêtises
c'est officiel c'est officieux c'est bon
tu as rome d'avoir un agent pour aller à
la draft s'il est certifié nci est
maintenant depuis un ou deux heures de
mémoire mais
rien n'est vraiment trop déclaré encore
voiture
williams qui est marqué comme ce qui est
quand même un des joueurs qui ont un
poids de standing rythme des plus grands
une des plus grandes de l'histoire
d'abord tu bats c'est vrai du bureau
avec eux noté à mieux que n'importe quoi
tacko fall et
un
autre que nous avait dit ben voilà on
avait fait voilà je crois qu'on avait
donné au nez à
81 8 mois mais c'est moi
donc là la couverture comme dire est
vertical mois les mains au dessus la
tarentule on passe pas je la remets ici
donc se jette pas ne se jette pas juste
on a dit
à l'ats il sait qu'il n'ya pas besoin de
ce fait c'est que si juste hier il aime
les bras
il n'y a aucune possibilité pour le
porteur de balle adverses car comme
jeremy roach qui est sous les 1 mètre 90
de pouvoir même prendre le tir quoi
c'est impossible donc c'est encore dans
ce qu'on disait la manière dont il fait
que continuer sur le terrain ça drive
beaucoup moins que le quand il n'est pas
sur le terrain on peut pas on peut
driver beaucoup plus facilement quand il
n'est pas là alors je redonnerai dessus
quand je parlais de changer de mains
regardez là on proteste main gauche on
va contester main gauche on va passer
sur la main droite parce qu'on voit que
le jour s'arrête pour passer volleyeurs
côté droit donc on pas sur la main
droite directement
road show triple i il est bloqué les
demain et là on écrase que toute
tentative de ne pas nous y voilà c'est
ça jure qu'elle ait vraiment des pauvres
fondamentaux défensifs et qui complaît
dans sa protection du panier
moubamba c'est moins hot mark williams
oui au stand et good chez moi au héros
envergure pur mark williams fois les
jours de cette envergure il n'y a pas de
ya pas de mystère je te laisse regarder
moi je mets le clip ici tu me le dis
et la gelée mis dans les références pour
ceux qui veulent regarder j'ai fait en
plus c'est le
moins le code castiglia un podcast vous
pouvez le 26 dans le meilleur à pourrir
donc sept pieds 4
il ya un peu d un podcast que vous
pouvez retrouver ici c'est l'avant
dernier avant michael de vos dons
n'hésitez pas pour plus d'informations
sur mark williams et je deviens j'étais
faire attention à
quasi un bon communicant là dessus tu
vois les réflexes lui a rien là on est
face à santa clara du coup président la
façon de gérer le compte a donc
effectivement il se fait repousser mais
tu le dis ça mais qui à cinq ans
c'est un mec à 24 en fin d'année contre
10,5 en cp sondage
est en fait c'est ce qu'on a vu sur deux
sur le 2-2 de mecs plus petit la c1
franck et il doit faire de 4 à peu près
de 5 c'est un petit intérieur mais aussi
un moyen de se dépêtrer de vue du
hauteur de brad de deutsch est quoi la
liste us un peu de à hello c'est pas
énormément on voit pas énormément voilà
la passe et les bonnes aller simple
allez faites moi j'essaie papin qui fait
des trucs super compliqué s'il fait des
choses simples mais très bien qu'il ait
répété c'est le plus important
après de toute façon dit on ne peut pas
toujours d'être nikola djokic ou quoi
c'est tout simplement d'autres vies le
pont des marquages et de prendre la
bonne décision quand il a le ballon non
moi je le vois très très bien exister
comme tu le dis aujourd'hui à vélo
capable d'être en hand of de rouler au
panier de poppée derrière capables quand
je réceptionne la balle après un rôle
donc sur mon rôle je réceptionne le
ballon tout de suite je peux cliquer
dans le corner rapidement voilà c'est
des choses simples mais qui vont
différencier le big men classique un peu
un peu brutal si l'ordre est leur mode
tiendraient leur donne un mec avec un
peu plus de finesse on me demande le
poids de mark williams alors moi
coulaines faut savoir que il a il fait
110 kg il la rumeur dernier 81 17 kg je
crois notre île a pris
quasiment quasiment 20 15 kg 20 km
l'année à une année de
mel a beaucoup mangé du côté du c'est ça
on va dire que tout est dans la bouffe
c'est ça
romain qui dit et c'est vrai sur le post
ali pourrait déserter un peu plus la
balle complètement c on voyait c'est ça
sent pas extrêmement naturelle je pense
que saint-georges chez les jeunes qui
donne qui est tous en fête est donc à y
apprendre peut-être plus de nuances sur
la palette offensive proche du panier
jacky très bien sûr la dila 80% produit
pas laissé assez incroyable et c'est un
axe prochain pour être encore plus
incroyable sur des finitions
là je regardais ce que j'avais d'autres
trucs sur notre ami chuck dans mes
propres pipe sur le côté tout tout tout
tout tout finalement dont on n'a pas
très bien parlé du shoot extérieur
on a vu qu'ils avaient remonté à 3
points dans la lutte et de la mécanique
de la dalle à distance qu'est ce que tu
en penses
on avait vu aussi donc c'est le premier
truc on nous parle de l'épreuve reine
depuis pas mal d'années on dit là il ya
une licorne qui tire
j'ai quasiment 2 m 20 et qui tire à
trois points soit moi je me dis ah non
on va regarder si l'on prend les stades
cette année il est il y a en total il ya
29 sur 62 à 3 points donc les après 62
tirs à trois points et c'est bien
septembre à la c c'est vraiment un
chiffre intéressant pour un intérieur
freshman
il avait été aussi très bons à trois
points je suis un peu voulu plus petits
lors de championnats du monde et le 19
il faut j'avais lu dans les commentaires
voilà il j'avais lu je les ai pas
trouvés très très bon championnat le 19
je pense qu'il faut arrêter de voir le
championnat u19 chez tom dwan par le
prisme de son match contre viktor hedman
yama il ya six autres matches n'était
pas une pipe pour rien victor wanyama
est un prospect incroyable historique
mais
t'es tu as we win quorum manama a été
meilleur que lui en finale mais cech a
été cloche dans ce match il a réussi à
le faire à faire prendre des photos à
victor il était bon sur la fin de fin de
match mais c'est un team player c'est
quand il a fallu donner la balle tu sais
à l'automne et ses avis aussi il a été
capable de le faire et dans d'autres
matchs quand il fallait être un peu de
leaders il a été aussi quelques raisons
que j'ai eu deux contre le canada où il
joue face un voyage at il vu pivot
canadien y dominent de notre opération
il donne également si vous profil lucas
gaza pendant le notre profil physique
qui est bien plus épais qui je crois
qu'ils étaient 105 110 kg il a pris la
mobilité tout en restant contre sans
faire de faute mais ça donc peut-être
vrai mais dans tous les contextes je les
ai vus
donc nominé à un peu quand il était avec
jallet une seule quand il avait joué au
début des matchs contre je vais en
baisse d'un match contre sierra c'était
il ya deux ans je crois donc en face et
les haïr williams et biz et boston et à
marie baylet une dream team de jeunes
ils avaient le choix je crois fait 14
contre 3 13 contre et il était genre
sophomore ou junior au lycée et donc il
y avait eu ultra dominé la peinture avec
l'équipe de team usa île à l'autre il a
dit aux mines incroyablement la peinture
avec conjugale dominant probablement la
voiture donc ce qu'on a vu c'est pas
juste mis en avant par le contexte braga
mis en avant parce qu' il est lié dans
un super super environnement il a
toujours été ça je pense qu'il faut les
mettre en avant aussi
c'est clair
10 est là dans les commentaires je vais
après deux là le diolof tonnes une
graine de match où chacun leur manière
alors pour tous ceux qui ne voient pas
qu'ils aient un japan a pas longtemps
kenneth lofton junior latin lover bec
d'oiseau
je vais vous le met ici alors c'est ça
que ça un profil et l'on se dit à watts
quand avec team usa et en fait c'est un
mec a beaucoup de finesse malgré encore
assez en fait c'est vraiment le le buste
qui est très très aimé le corps le clap
sont valables et et pourtant il ya des
bras très développé des bonhommes
externe au quick quand vous voyez ces
images la bomba peut se demander
est ce que c'est vraiment un jour de
team us elle oui c'est un jour de team
usa à la comparaison avec hamilton qui a
de très belles finesse qui bouge très
très bien qu a beaucoup touché et qui a
détruit des joueurs par cette situation
hors ex-palerme à une sphère louisiana
tech dont conférence succès en 17 11 oui
je suis content rue qui monte alabama je
l'avais vu un technicien c'est un genre
dominant avec un des très bonnes mains
et est vraiment un très fort joueur
initié ces moments parce que chet lui il
est très grand et très maigre et nuit
est plus petit et plus épais pas parce
qu'il fait de m pour 120 kg froid de
l'automne quelque chose comme ça
je regardais un eurostar ne ratez une
question est ce que il est grand depuis
longtemps tu sais ton et secouer parce
qu'elle a grandi à cet art alors j'ai
pas eu énormément d'infos là dessus
alors je suis trouvé un truc sur 6 kw et
si je dois dire que tu as le
référencement parlera pour notre système
à nous il faisait un mètre quatre vingt
trois avait 88 ans stx coûts et donc 6
quid
de mémoire
je crois que c'est la dernière année des
liens militaires donc en gros c'est du
10 au 11 août voilà m 88 ans 11
voilà moi je suis à 1083 par exemple mes
élèves de cm2 à l'hormadi grandissent
plus en plus un gamin de 2 cm 2
classique c'est un mètre 55 km 65
maintenant m sakho son papa son papa
donc été un très fort joueur
universitaire de mémoire et qui veulent
être remis et ce dans le minnesota et du
minnesota il est de mettre 13 sont pas
parus et donc voit donc ses joues
j'y suis allé à celle amicale pour
s'habiller c'est le galère quoi
on va me demander s'il y avait des un
passif de
de blessures chez ce joueur pareil j'ai
jamais trouvé de grosses blessures chez
de 7 ans youmzain donc donc voilà paré
qu'est ce que je dis souvent c'est ce
que je dis souvent on passe est normal
qu'on ait des doutes sur le profil
athlétique le profit mais il n'a jamais
eu une grosse blessure s'est il a jamais
vraiment raté deux matchs il sait jamais
casser quelque chose donc on comprend
qu'on ne soit pas vers la victoire mais
victor a eu plus de petits pépins
physiques ou que katia factor on a
souvent un petit problème où je vis à
des poulets s'est également que chez
fiat on ne retrouve pas mal gré assure
qu'il a beaucoup on contacte pour pour
un peu finale sur le jeu pour les choses
qu'on a un peu moins une autre est là et
si on ne peut pas tout montrer on pourra
on pourrait en faire des cessions et de
plaisir et à tous
je je me plains souvent de la qualité
des écrans des intérieurs initiés qui ne
savent plus prend un écran qui est un
organe pose de très bons et grands c'est
un joueur qui met encore une fois de
l'impact et qui arrive à trégunc
décalage sur le défenseur du porteur de
balle et qui crée un surnombre donc là
dessus encore une fois c'est un mec a
pas peur du contact et qui a contrario
la plupart des jeunes américains et
n'diaye c'est ce que ça veut dire c'est
ce que s'est posée à un écran donc une
qualité c'est un jour qui protège le
rebond avec dubai that have a dream même
si c'est pas lui qui capture les rues
moins d'argent qu'ils sont fous
l'important c'est que l'équipe le
récupèrent la possession et donc il
sacré qui sont encore on va boxer on va
regarder où elle défenseurs ont banalisé
la géométrie du ballon et je mettrai du
tir et on va se passer à la bonne place
donc on parle de ses chances y est
aujourd'hui choix du combat dans son dos
voilà je voulais revenir là dessus et
peut-être chance à difficultés
défensives je le dis c'est pas evan
n'oublie pas ce que c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas une bille et tout et c'est pas
voilà ce qu'il se fait prendre journée
cette époque on a peut être une
faiblesse qui peut avoir le changement
de direction très vite sur des tirs ça
c'est ça encore une faiblesse qui là
qu'il a été mal ou le changement de
direction hyper rapide avec un tiers il
est en complexifiant l'est en difficulté
et enfin une chose qu'ils maîtrisent
très bien que vous allez souvent voir ci
dessus est en grève aujourd'hui jour du
dribble pour compenser le fait que ce ne
soit pas hyper foot qui n'arrivent pas à
changer demain j'enlève frontale ils
maîtrisent très bien le spin move c'est
un jour que vous avez souvent partie en
main droite spin move je finis à gauche
ou bien je pars main gauche et ça c'est
souvent ça en fait je pars à gauche spin
move je repars chaumont à droite pour
terminer ou bien je qui dans le corner
c'est une action typique de tangram que
vous pouvez voir à deux fois par match
et qu'on pourra trouver au niveau qui
est encore une fois la comparaison filet
avec evans public il le faisait déjà
très bien ici s est pas là cette
capacité à se débarrasser de son
défenseur parce que je suis très très
long je suis dacc eu l'air et avec un
spin je vais prendre le dessus sur
surtout maudire sûrement défense en
direct il ya julien qu'il est isolé en
difficulté en u19 sur les petit meneur
est ce qu'on retrouve aussi on ici et
sur les mecs très vivants qu'ils peuvent
et ça franchement faut utiliser a
commencé tout à l'heure sont guidés en
disant sûr beaucoup font d'hydro point
de vue et pour arrêter vous de vouloir
faire switcher tous les grands simon mon
site et un brin il se fait prendre en
contre par triangle de la mort entre
deux gares ou d'autres parce que c'est
pas voilà c'est pas très grave c'est
quand tout le monde je pense donc tu
vois ya déjà pas mal de gens qui se
posaient la question de
la défense du jazz la décence de de
cleveland et c'est en fait cette défense
qui vont obliger soit à prendre mes
distances soit à mourir pas le tir
extérieur et on se rend compte du fait
que c'est très très dur sur 45 minutes
de ne marquer que jour du tir extérieur
finalement on admet que la série fait
que très bien cleveland qui te dire tu
vas voir détention ouvert patronat des
grands que evans mobile peut pas une si
l'extraordinaire peut pas couvrir il va
aller retour quand des canards corner tu
vas prendre des tirs extérieurs mais on
tend pédaler au cercle ce que fait une
nouveau qui est ce que fait qu'ils
vendent ce que fait du guitariste pour
ça ne s'est pas mis des meilleures
défenses au queens où vous allez voir
ces joueurs là cependant tient entre
pendant la phase se prendre un step back
être en retard sur un décalage mais par
rapport au volume de tirer par rapport à
l'efficacité de cette cire au fur et à
mesure du match quelque chose de positif
donc non non pas de souci là-dessus moi
j'ai aucun problème avec le fait que
s'il avait des défenseurs capables de
stopper un drive c'est à l'extérieur ça
aiderait énormément réunion de toute
façon tu as été chez first il n'est pas
très longtemps juste passé quand watine
t on la veut en libre hôtels ou dans une
autre émission il en parlait
finalement les joueurs de utah se repose
sur midi pour défendre et comme c'est
l'un des meilleurs défenseurs leur
théorie en tout cas et je la partage
comme c'est un des meilleurs défenseurs
lui font plus l'effort est derrière du
coup il y aura de nombreuses héroïque à
tout faire
françois qui nous demandent une graine
dans le jeu sans ballon ça donne quoi
est-ce qu'il est bonne le démarquage
mettre en avant sur l'efficacité je
pense où il vit et meurt avec son
pick-up à trois points si je te laisse
aller là où
on a dit alors que je devais surtout
c'est quasiment du 50 50 entre
projectiles panier et 3 points donc il
la plupart de ces termes ou et ça va
être compliqué n'y pas pas trois points
il peut aussi en prendre tout seul un
petit dribble un pied voilà mais en fait
il vit aussi proche du cercle et donc
c'est très bien pour lui parce que c'est
des trucs à voter sur des choux tard au
pourcentage de ce qu'il réussit bien
donc il ya ce qui fait toi tu es
musulman
mais non ils jouent avec quelques
bagnoles qu'est ce qui la met poste bas
lui il va être à l'opposé le corner est
ce qu'il est capable de venir une
surcharge dans le dans le cut proposer
des solutions se replaçait peut-être
dans l'axé pour pouvoir signer une prise
à deux récupérer la balle est terminée
voilà ce qu'est une intelligence et une
bonne mobilité dans le old town ou pour
toiser pour l'instant un joueur qui
reste campé derrière dani d'extérieur ou
qui est près du cercle et qui bouge
touchant littéralement dublin c'est pas
un joueur qui bouge énormément mais
c'est aussi je pense view des athlètes
différents systèmes dans lesquels il a
joué
il fallait servir beaucoup de monde je
pense que c'est un joueur sur qui on
peut dessiner quelques jeux pour leur
rendre un peu un peu libre est par
contre ont cependant que c'est un
incroyable
hunter un incroyable jean repos dans la
démarcation c'est un finisseur d'actions
pour qui on va qui à qui on va mettre on
va mais on va le mettre au moins deux
positions plutôt qui va se mettre en
bonne position je pense
avec mobile mais un joueur qui façon pas
contre la taxe sur lui la défense sur
lui et de confinement le système ça
devient lui par la force des choses et
du coup la note hybride là-dedans quoi
et jusqu'à l'impression eux qui va
naturellement pouvoir se replacer au bon
endroit surtout quand il est dans
l'express du cercle sur un pick and roll
the trance mois leur place rapidement
même si c'est l'un des grands à leur
tour on sait par un joueur de floppy
c'est pas c'est pas un mec qui va faire
corner kuyt dans laxe je donne coup je
reviens et cetera mais voilà si j'ai
quelqu'un de fonctionnel qui comprend le
jeu qui va être passée au bon endroit
souhaite voir des énormes déplacement et
défensivement jour tout cela on le
retrouvera c'est pas un mec qui va
courir gauche à droite gauche droite
mais qui va porter l'aide qui va monter
sa présence tu vois par exemple ligne de
fond je dois me je suis côté faible
j'aimerais passer sous le panier je me
remets etc avec des petits déplacements
intelligents mais qui va toujours notre
moi c'est entre la ligne de base
l'attaquant etc qui va casser ça on nous
demande de question est ce qu'il ya un
type de côte qui lui irait mieux moi je
répondrai un coach qui le fait jouer
déjà
un coach qui comprend ce qu'est cet
homme grain et qui essaye pas d'en faire
un automne idelis ce qui serait une
oeuvre de l'auteure tu es un pic 1 tu
prends le ballon tu marques je pense que
c'est plus parce qu'il irait le mieux
c'est pas forcément un coach mais c'est
qu'il y a fort porteur de balle en tout
cas un bon porteur de balle ils se
retrouvent pas comme des intérieurs
qu'on a vu arriver à une bille et qui
avait pas de meneurs ces dernières
années ndlr evans moblie est-ce qu'il a
le même impact à cleveland si la patte
arrière avant de savoir les deux sens
mais je pense que ricky rubio et ricky
rubio évidemment ces collines textone je
pense que c'est pas
toi tu l'as vécu aussi gelé qu avec wade
à tanger durée le rythme reconnaît mark
allen on va une mineure qui maintenant
vivent beaucoup mieux avec colin kenny
chesney sexe et pour marc années noah
bio et car land et andrei tonnes les
landes righton avant cris avant avant
rubio et chris paul est donc la première
année sera même jour
la scène a eu la chance lui l'a eue
connaît évidemment je vous dis je là
dessus aussi c'est les objets rue
d'auxonne junior pourquoi est-ce que je
prenais pas evan moblie en en 1 tu vois
il est peut-être pour que je n'aie pas
le chaton 1 et des rédactions du nord
est s'était raté parce que c'est des
joueurs qui ont bénéficié du fait que
derrière on fait juste avant il ya top
profil extérieur qui puisse l'aimer
tablette exxon junior je pense que même
s'ils sont au fond du trou mais verizon
j'ignore si y'a pas
mort
npc kamer et dit je vous dis à drenthe
heure par exemple car j'aime paraît pas
vous regardiez paraître regardez moi de
prendre we don't un exemple
ensuite on nous en demande tout de
graines c'est le joueur qui peut
apporter une franchise sa première année
alors dans la liste de tous les joueurs
je sais pas c'est dur c'est dur à savoir
et c'est dur parce que c'est dur parce
que pour moi c'est un joueur qui va
jouer dans la vingtaine de minutes un
plus
comme tous les acteurs ewan meublé voilà
eurosis est anormale ce qui fait jouer
autant défendre aussi bien si jeune
c'est pas noël peut être que tu as tu
vas le faire s'il le fait je serais
extrêmement heureux mais lorsque la
production statistiques offensives d'un
bang héros peut être un peu peut-être
plus forte sur les premières années la
capacité des cartes est le terreau est
tirée jabbari ce n'est peut être pas mal
mais défensivement oui ce sera pour moi
le rookie est que plus d'impact c'est ça
il va changer une défausse on va créer
une force comme le fait mme hanoune
l'icom le ferry jean gaubert et ses
séjours de profils générationnel
défensif mais oui comme tu le dis pour
le bonheur on mettra des points des
nanas et vie mettra du ritz à paris
mettra du space in donc voilà ça
dépendra de la wii tombe
et
pour pouvoir aider coéquipiers qui le
rend donc dur à dire mais ce sera un
jour très impactant j'en suis persuadé
aussi est interne les 3 4 ans et
peut-être un des jours les plus
impactants de sa cuvée en tout cas c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qu'on pense cette
confiance ici on en a près du ketch est
sa pulpe à ce qui est oui ou non du 10
hockey ici c'est bien au style voilà qui
sera parfait partout sk une franchise là
comme ça ou demain au lendemain ellaone
dan carter est mort en bas mais même
orlando il peut jouer dan carter en fait
ce que je veux et tu te dis tout le
temps il tire donc tu peux le mettre
avec un bon tireur par imiter la
mobilité web de l'us douala est ce qu'il
ya une équipe quand même tu aimerais le
plus de voir tomber même si c'est pas
forcément une équipe là debout au top
five mais tu vois avec la loterie équipe
dans l'élite en du pélican parce que
parce que c'est le profil pour mata côté
design
systems merde désolé pour les fans des
plages j'aime beaucoup votre logo je
trouve ça cool c'est sympa le côté etc
mais d'afrique c'est tellement le bordel
oui c'est le bordel mais tu vois c'est
brian ça serait d'ailleurs ne serait pas
le bon c'est vrai ya pas de meneur mais
déjà ils peuvent rien il peut en prendre
et en fait c'est le sait le profil de
joueur qui est parfait petit cm parce
que comme ça ce n est le seul bon tireur
zion à a dû un contre un dans la
peinture donc il y totalement
inarrêtable et chet peut protéger le
cercle est un peu et joue hexagone donc
ça c'est un petit peu le le fitr qui me
fait un peu un peu un peu rêver mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas de meneur pour
lui pour le mettre en place pour servir
apprécié des rationnements d'eau ni gaz
ce qui est ça ma pression que j'ai pas
rester debout l'histoire sinon ouais ok
ici des trois très bien qu'ils sont
antonio a de la chance ou si j'arrive à
à monter je pense que c'est un profil
intéressant autour de tous leurs jeunes
un peu un peu sur les experts
pourtant tous et pourtant on a de la
chance oui c'est pourtant on a de la
chance honnêtement c'est un joueur au
profil tellement rare mais en même temps
qu'il peut tellement être recherché par
ce qui peut avoir le délire book lopez
master en héros du jeu protège le serge
de tirs à trois points
tout le monde doit être intéressé par ce
jour-là orlando les roquettes voilà les
roquettes ça que j'appelle au sacramento
autres pour monde peut être intéresser
plus d'un 15h06 jeter des produits nés
ces plages horaires choisis nous sommes
très plaisir d'avoir sacramento de 30
ans avait été sauvée - sacramento ils
veulent aller très bien mais les nazis
sacramento parce que parce que tu as eue
halliburton et etcheto nolan ça me fait
kiffer c'est pas à nous athlétiques mais
c'est rod et des gens nouveaux
comportements anglais ni les proches
alliés parfait il ya un prochain billet
sauf compléter leur ici quand il valait
sont un peu dans le collectif moins
marquée
mais toujours être là défensivement ils
échouent tuerie selon le collectif mais
il ya des moments où il sait que c'est
un peu à lui de prendre des outils mais
tant qu'à l'essence en galère et il peut
demander le ballon weather vas-y tu
donnes moi la balle je vais mettre un
panier je vais prendre un tir hélas pas
peur il faut mettre un poulpe la
transition il propre réseau n'y a pas
d'hésitation donc il ya un côté un peu
aidé du physique est la volonté de tuer
en attaque en défense donc voilà il ya
ya un comportement de jours dominos
et défensivement c'est un alpha tout il
va toujours au contact ton fiche de ce
phénomène qui tue pourtant il va
contester t1 franchement ça a l'air
d'être un super tous les joueurs qui
étaient cruelles qui meurent et c'est
cet été avait l'air de dire que c'était
sûrement super super leader l'équipe
voit que du positif on appuiera sur
bolton il est bien content que tu es un
gars qui n'entrent pas dans le ballon
pour pouvoir troquer comment comme un
cochon tout l'amour que j'ai pour
assurer bolton et ruthy me voici les
commandes le moustachu d'avoir ses sept
tirs près du panier